[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir
je rappelle qu'il est le seul à ce
gp tickets sont à vous poser ce soir
si vous voulez galets vous voyez pas sur
moi
ce n'est pas
avéré que vous voyez l erika p
mais c'est vrai
ce n'est dû qu'à des
jeux n'est pas réservé à l'iss
et encore je ne parle de la vanille tous
oui
mais j'ai vu les images
que vous ne valez pas
interdit
d'y pas de réussite
allait de l'arabe
illimitée
si c'est soit
j'aime le métier de boue sous peu mais
je peux vous dire que ça je ne peux pas
parce que si andy kapp et elle a aussi
appelé le port est
oui mais quand j'ai un jour c'est pas
l'heure où des pôles de la paix 2006
après ce
et à ce que siné deuxième famille pour
demander quel était le double a de la
classe
alors ayez le courage d'une cité vit
dans les études et geslin donne raison
mais quand gr et images qui s'appelle
illimité réussi aller de l'avant
faut pas perdu de l'espoir
quand j'ai quitté voir seulement j'ai
commencé à la bastille sable
sur la vache et dix salles à ce moment
lui des chalets ne dépassait pas
grâce à ou 500 francs maximum
végétal de la roja
puisque je pouvais faire quelque chose
pour m'exprimer dans le prince salmane
avait par la sarl mahdia donc j'étais
très content ici qu il
m'est arrivé
j'ai vécu avec moi si tu es gens à
ramasser du south side a pu compliquer
avec moi
donc j'ai décidé d'une panne du pétrole
j'ai pris l'argent mais j'ai mal à la
merci du sable à l'épée périt type de
pétrole pour information
gère ses choix
c'est jeudi je passais du porte à porte
revenus du pétrole et les affameurs
couple a appelé al-zawiya du bélier le
book de s'asseoir
oui j'ai fait ça ont moins de poids
valromey car assidu de pétrole bat soir
j'étais très très prenant à partie du
cahier de plus
puisque kg ramacity salle dans cette
lettre le poteau parce que je paye
rapport quelque chose vous remettez
telle force dans le savoir donner du
courage d'aller de l'avant mais à un
moment donné
j'ai aussi dit que
avec est délicate et une fois à brac qui
métier
donc été décidé de la dose simple du
procès du travail
les à vouloir
gérer
l ou des personnes handicapées qui fait
de l'artisanat
dont 1,2 à cannes berthelaise
habitude fait l'apprentissage la teaser
nous ce genre
de l'artisanat
ben ali est à l appétit non plus aux
pelles et les hommes et des dieux nous
fabriquons aller à côté des hôtels
résa massage là où je peux et apprécié
de tous au pouvoir alors
l'artisanat de nos pratiques en
salles le 2
que j'ai décidé de créer l autre bout le
personnel handicapé
nous sommes tous des personnes et du
quart des
salariés de l'artisanat
en fabrique
déjà la fin on fabrique des éducatifs
nous faire les tables des mariages et à
leur décoration nous fait lors de la
création de l'inflation
peux-tu me contre l autre axe est ouest
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes très fiers parce qu'on
arrive de gains et deux points à venger
on allie des nourrit la fin on a les
deux pays en fin d'études noah fin et le
sol est très porteur
avec ses chars et le serveur on n'a pas
ce que nous ne sommes pas des handicapés
pourquoi tu ne nous ne sommes pas des
mendiants droit de la rue pour mardi
l'orgueil nous sommes très potable à
linselles en belle et pilier du ciel de
l'europe de l'amérique de l'afrique et
peu partout dans le monde pour lui et
d'autres objets d'art voile et le bal
nous sommes très très porteur avec serge
july
jerry le plus à l'aise que les
ministères de la jeunesse va vous faire
et puis les élus minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
délicates et puis tu viens de l'autre le
ministère surtout avec quelqu'un qui est
né de la main gauche donc est il
vraiment vraiment très potes
je vous parle ce soir salle basly que
j'ai fait des millions ou des milliards
comme bill gates and amérique où les
bobards burkina faso
d'ailleurs des services ayant fait la
présentation ce soir ils vont avoir
beaucoup des ovations parce que les
êtres milliards pour moitié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'aucuns comme ça que ce soir c'est à
l'endroit à tous et qui sont découragés
à tous et à tous ceux qui ne croient
plus à la vie à tous et qu'ils sont
désespérés à tous et lissant leurs
symboles qui ne fait que pleurer tu dit
mot le gars est au fond la barre et
petit étal l'espoir du grimp le verbe ou
des pâtes à bach à ce que tu veux ces
cieux que tu vas y arriver
tu vas arriver là où tu veux dire
capable c'est suffit de te faire
confiance ça va aller et puis hop
hommage aux
divas évitant
au message ce soir
ça va la drr
roger 10h06 on balise et critiqué la
pâte travail suit pas la voie avec peu
parce que six mois à taguer niqab et tu
perds van poppel
c'était un peu du père travaillait pour
le moule et ma famille s'est pas attaqué
ou balit tickets repas du travail
recherché pour créer une fois avoir un
esprit de travail et puis mutuelle des
états si tu commences tu vas y arriver
il faut avoir du courage de travail il
faut avoir une idée du travail il ça va
aller
je parle avec mes jeunes frères et
soeurs qui sont éducateurs au moins qui
prend les victimes est de voir pourquoi
mais j'ai du bon mais n'écarte pas la
laïcité
les beckham c'est pas la misère les 10
car c'est pas la fatalité unique à celle
physique énorme le l'esprit
j'essaie superstar et qui est plus fort
que moi un
atelier sels de bain puisque moins
chers les cabs et il fait la liste est
là à la maison aussi tu fais de boules
de l'élevage à l'herbe global dû plaire
aux masses plus de sa poule se marient
nobels lors des séries
celui-ci se situe qu'au bas ce qui va
arriver ici que te manque seulement
deux décisions issues que de mal elle
est ce du collage pour pouvoir y arriver
six mois tu peux arriver à taguer lkp
qui n'a qu'un monsieur le maire pousse
tellement d aller de l'avant
ce soir
pareil d'haïti que le dollar était alors
travaillé pour tenir des
barrages de la liberté c'est le travail
qui n'émet plus ce que yann sommer moi
ce qui me dit 'il petit parole
savoir pour les jades w
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]